[Applause]
happy Tuesday everyone I am Tom Shalo in
for Greg Gutfeld who I'm told is busy
fighting
extradition so before we get to the news
I thought it might be appropriate to
look at some of the New Year's
resolutions from some famous names and
faces for example President Joe Biden
his New Year's resolution contined to
cheat
death
so Hunter Biden find that envelope I
left somewhere in the White
House Commander the dog eat more salads
and fewer Secret Service
agents Camala Harris to resolve to make
resolutions for the new year because
it's new and it's a
year
right I might add uh uh stop laughing
that might help too
the custodian who cleans the Senate
Judiciary Committee room three words use
more
bleach Brian killme I will continue to
be the butt of Greg's
jokes and finally Randy wiin Garten add
40 pounds to my bench
press she'll make it okay onto the
monologue so I'm looking over tonight's
headlines trying to think of the perfect
story to start the show massive migrant
Caravan heading to the US Mexico border
is largest in over a year the New York
Times turns its editorial page over to
Hamas and AOC tweets Merry Christmas and
by the way Jesus was a Palestinian
refugee each one more ridiculous than
the next and then there's this a Daily
Mail poll finds that voters describe
their 2024 choice between a trump second
term and a Biden second term as a choice
between revenge or nothing but is it
really Revenge that Trump voters want
want and is the Biden presidency really
about nothing there may be no good
things happening but that doesn't mean
nothing is happening there is a sense in
our country that things have gone off
the rails and even Liberals are noticing
I'm thinking of people like noted
feminist Martina neverova realizing
wokeness is killing women's sports Dave
Chappelle refusing to allow a few
privileged groups to decide what he's
allowed to think and say or celebrated
liberal Democrat Barry Weiss who's not
so celebrated anymore now that thinks
and writes for herself or Bill Moore he
keeps telling fellow liberals hey slow
down we're ruining everything guys look
at this recent rant by Mah and I have
one piece of advice for the Youth of
America don't go to college opening
America's eyes to how higher education
has become indoctrination into a stew of
bad ideas among them the simplistic
notion that the world is a binary place
where everyone is either an oppressor or
oppressed
he went on to say things like if
ignorance is a disease Harvard Yard is
the Wuhan
Market to Applause from his liberal
audience like anyone who stays at a
Motel 6 when things get this bad you
have to wake up so Bill Mah like many
other American liberals has noticed
American education and liberalism in
general is about illiberal things like
quashing free speech and separating
people into groups based on their race
and outlawing debate but here's what I
found most interesting his conclusions
about Elite schools like Harvard sure
they occasionally turn out someone
decent but for every Barack Obama there
are two Josh
holes the former debate team who had no
friends that no one likes today and yet
somehow manages to win a Statewide
popularity contest you see they still
can't quit their patron saint of cool
Barack Obama don't they understand
everything that's bad about our country
today our crumbling cities an army of
migrants crossing the border the
weaponization of our intelligence
Services the woke mind virus that's
taken over Corporate America it's all a
project of Obama Inc remember him
socializing medicine as Obamacare as if
a guy living in a $30 million morus
Vineyard Hideout cares about anything
except making sure the help keeps his
pool clean his spreading the wealth
around that's funny how much of it was
spread to him and his friends his
International Red Line that vanished
faster than Gutfeld when the dinner
check
arrives ask Jesse his pivot to Asia well
China just told Biden they're taking
Taiwan any day now Mitch McConnell
playing pickle ball pivots better than
Obama there's an old saying that
American politics is played between the
40 yard lines that was Barack Obama he
took us into the left's end zone and the
Dems haven't left sense so the chaos you
see around you is on purpose that's the
leftist plan if you want to make an
omelet you got to break some eggs you
got to tear down Society so you can
rebuild it in your image that's always
been how the left achieves Utopia let
out enough murderers and people will beg
for the secret police so the Democrats
may lose in 2024 for all the wrong
reasons sure Biden is old and
incompetent but it's the liberal
policies themselves that have hurt the
country even when Obama Ed in his ideas
with youth and confidence didn't matter
the policies still failed some call
Biden's presidency Obama 2.0 it's like a
tattoo on an 81-year-old
sometimes horrible ideas get worse over
time here he is let's welcome our
guest he's like an eagle patriotic bald
and attacks people with his toenails and
his now you know tour starts in February
comedian Jim
Norton he knows overcoming adversity
like being a guest on this show Fox News
contributor Johnny Joey
Jones he's so smart Harvard's president
refuses to plagiarize him campus reform
higher education fellow Nicholas
jordano and she might be blonde but she
won't get ConEd host of The Hoop chat
Emily a
all right Joey what do you think it this
idea that Liberals are now waking up but
then to hear Bill Mah say oh if we can
only just go back to Obama doesn't he
realize what Obama wrot that's why we're
here does he realize it or he's still a
part of it right it's I don't trust any
of them that are that are turning on
Biden right now because there are a lot
of reasons to turn on Biden have nothing
to do with ideology there are a lot of
reasons to turn on Biden right he's not
a safe horse to bet on he's he's the
horse that kind of passes out and loses
in turn two I mean I I can't go back to
Barack Obama I can just hear him in my
head right now saying the war is over
we're going to leave Afghanistan if you
want your legs you can keep your legs
and and you know none of those
things none of those things were true I
I don't need Obama we're getting Obama
tag three right now everyone Joe Biden
has employed worked in the Obama
Administration they were not very good
at it so they got a promotion in the
Biden Administration there you go Emily
the do you see people waking up like I
said we have a lot of people on the left
I mentioned Barry Weiss uh you know
kicked out of the New York Times now she
started her own operation uh do you
think they're waking up or not I think
that there's like a small minority
that's getting louder but the majority I
hope I really hope so majority of the
left seem to actually start to Value
life and anyone with the slightest bit
of Common Sense is going to understand
the traj eory that the United States is
going on we're going to be screwed if
something doesn't change if we have four
more years of whatever is going on right
now we're all in big trouble so I don't
think enough people are waking up but I
hope that I'm wrong and I hope that by
election time we don't allow America to
keep going down this road because we are
all going to screw ourselves Nicholas
can I call you Nick or how do you do it
you call me Nick we call you Nick okay
I've been noticing this Obama worship
from people who I think are starting to
wake up now they call Joe
right-wing he's not right-wing he's been
a liberal he's just like Bill Mah and
you know he's he's always seen many
sides of the issue but even he I want to
put up this quote here this was from his
podcast I noticed he says he can't get
enough of Obama but as far as like a
representative of the United States who
better than Obama he's the best of all
time the most educated and eloquent and
even killed I mean what is he talking
about does he does he not recognize the
policies because Biden actually thinks
he is Obama 2.0 well that's the thing I
mean people look at President Biden and
they'll make attacks oh his policies are
horrible but it's the policies no matter
who you replace him with those same
policies stay in effect and the idea of
wokeism has destroyed higher education
and and our society it's extraordinarily
destructive I mean at campus reform we
talked about these Equitable grading
systems what better way to achieve
success than to drop all standards have
a plagiarizer become the president of
Harvard University yeah and then say
that's acceptable and justify it so we
see the failures of oism people are
starting to wake up but it took protests
calling for a genocide against Jews for
people to say maybe the movement's gone
a little too far it should have been
when they were talking about gender
ideology to kindergarteners and the
anti-americanism that's been pumped in
the University system every bad idea has
filtered out through the colleges and
we're seeing it in real time actually
did you hear about this that Obama is
actually behind the scenes he's pulling
uh for claudian gay from harage he wants
her to keep keep the job he's trying to
convince the board to keep her if that
is true I don't know if it is but why
would he be doing that you think that
Obama why does he want to hold on to
that when she's obviously uh you know
her credibility has been severely
damaged it has but our entire profession
has been damaged if I fail a student for
plagiarizing now they could turn around
and be like well the Harvard president
plagiarized and nothing happened to her
why am I failing and this is the
embarrassment to our profession as
people that teach and are supposed to
educate that it's not about education
anymore it's about virtue signaling it's
about emotions and it's about an agenda
to push and that's the thing former
president Obama wants Claud gay there to
push an agenda Jim I never know where
you're going to come from I was
mentioning guys like that like Rogan
doesn't see party you know he he takes
on each issue Chappelle's the same way
you're probably the same way what are
your what would you say to the American
people coming up for 2024 I don't think
Bill Mar has changed I don't think any
of these guys have changed they're just
reacting to a younger generation which
is more radical uh the same as
traditional conser conservatives don't
embrace all the far-right ideology
traditional liberals don't embrace all
every insane thing that woke uh ideology
says this is not new I I don't even
think Obama started it he definitely
pushed it but I mean you look back to
when Clinton was President and he said
uh yeah I believe in political
correctness they started the language
policing 30 years ago and in 1988 nobody
came to dice's uh rescue when he got in
trouble for saying dirty words The
Comedians have been telling you this for
over 30 years they and now that it's
happening more and more every uh PE
group that's being affected is going oh
my God how could they come how could
they allow this in in girl Sports how
could they allow this but nobody cared
when it was 30 years ago and guys were
getting in trouble for for jokes so this
started a long time ago it hasn't
changed it has just gotten progressively
worse but I don't even fault Obama for I
I mean this was long before him at this
started yeah I guess I could say that
you know I said most of the troubles in
this country Joey have to do with Obama
policies but that's just in the modern
world I don't think he's a particularly
more evil than any other politician he's
just just been more effective he come
out came out of that Chicago School of
politics and you know he was a community
organizer people used to make fun of
that I'll never forget when Sarah Palin
made fun of him saying oh I have a real
job he was a community organizer
Community organizer is a real job and it
has more of effect on this country than
most people realize if you live where I
live a community organizer is a hell of
a job I mean you got to go 10 miles to
find somebody to organize I mean so I
mean I've always respected that uh but
listen you want to see will this is an
effect in today's world look at Gavin
new
I mean California is an absolute mess
there's nothing about him I particularly
like but if I host Fox and Friends
Rachel is going to say oh you know it he
comes across charismatic that's what
people think they think and who cares
you know that he's ruined the best piece
of land we've ever had California
doesn't matter he's somehow charismatic
that was Barack Obama and that is what I
think Gavin Newsome wants to do is ride
that Charisma into the White House the
way that Obama did it okay before we go
a quick reminder you can come see my
solo show spontaneous combustion oh look
at that picture I'll be in Albany
Syracuse Stanford Connecticut Harford
Boston and Providence go to Tom sho.com
for tickets and info and up next yeah go
ahead give me a little love there hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else